on this Tuesday night Reading Writing
arithmetic and resignations it is a
crisis situation what's causing the
Nationwide shortage of teachers the
Ontario Premier Under Pressure over the
green belt they're going to review the
whole process the reaction and what's at
stake over this contentious land swap
Convoy leaders on trial what the
prosecution hopes to prove plus whom the
defense is trying to stop from
testifying and flipping the script to
how Hollywood strikes can't stop some
big stars
from attending Canada's biggest Film
Festival
global national with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us well
there was plenty of excitement no doubt
some butterflies and tears for little
ones as students of all ages headed back
to class today it's time for them to
reconnect with friends and meet new
teachers but teachers are in short
supply these days across Canada
especially in Quebec more than 8 500
positions there are unfilled 1800
teaching positions are full-time 6600
are part-time nitu garcha reports on the
hardest hit areas and what's behind the
critical shortage of educators
their backpacks are filled with school
supplies but the supply of teachers in
schools across Canada is low I think it
all comes back to lack of funding it's
not as much as we need we are in a
crisis situation funded so teachers are
not working to the Bone having major
health issues mental health issues that
make them quit the profession overworked
and underappreciated teachers across
Canada their unions and school boards
are sounding the alarm about the impact
on them and students we are pulling from
our specialized teachers to fill
classrooms and so those kids that need
the additional supports aren't receiving
them even folks that have been in the
system for 20 plus years they're leaving
students are heading back to classes
here in BC a day after the premier
acknowledge the shortage as a serious
issue not limited to teachers yes there
is a challenge getting teachers but
there's challenges across many areas of
hiring in British Columbia to find the
people we need BC teachers say the terms
of their Collective agreements aren't
being met they are unable to fulfill
their duty to ensure that our class
sizes and composition are being met prop
times is there for us to prepare for
classrooms but when you get pulled out
of your prep time as well then it just
loads on to experts point to population
surges and an older education Workforce
as part of the problem in Ontario's peel
region most high schools have seen
regular class cancellations in the past
year due to the teacher shortage last
year we had 54 secondary teachers in the
Peel District School Board resigned and
then we had 10 more resignations over
the summer
that those numbers are unprecedented the
situation is dire in Quebec where
certified substitutes are hard to find
across the country Advocates agree with
higher costs of living and growing
demands on teachers it all comes down to
Provincial Government funding if they
really valued having a world-class
public education system in Ontario they
would put their money where their mouth
is because they're not due doing that
there is that fear that which of my
students won't get the support they need
if I need help who do I go to need
Global News Surrey BC
the last long weekend of Summer was
difficult for dozens of kids and parents
in Calgary after an outbreak of E coli
at six Calgary daycares Alberta Health
Services says up to 50 children were
brought to the hospital
the pain these kids feel in their guts
is
it is heartbreaking they're so little
and they don't understand and you can't
do anything about it
daycare administrators say the source of
the outbreak is under investigation but
believe it came from food made in a
communal kitchen five other sites that
share that kitchen have also declared
outbreaks and been closed E coli can
cause diarrhea stomach cramping nausea
and vomiting symptoms typically appear
one to ten days after contaminated food
is consumed
Ontario's Premier is responding to
intense criticism of his government's
plan to open up protected land to a
small group of well-connected developers
the province's auditor general has said
those developers stand to make billions
yesterday Doug Ford's housing Minister
Steve Clark resigned after a scathing
report by the province's Integrity
commissioner found Clark violated ethics
rules and today Ford says the whole
process will be re-evaluated
I've asked my new minister of Municipal
Affairs and Housing to launch this
review and as part of this process
re-evaluate the remaining land swap
sites these sites these proposals will
have to survive on their own Merit the
green belt is 810 000 hectares of
protected land around Toronto intended
to restrict urban sprawl and preserve
ecosystems with me from the legislature
in Toronto is calling Demello hi there
Colin how is Premier Ford's promise of a
review of this being received well the
premier's political critics Donna are
calling this a doubling down of flawed
policy the premier is essentially saying
that after reviewing two million Acres
of this Greenbelt Land that additional
lands could be opened up for Housing
Development some see this as open season
on the green belt because the premier
failed to answer key questions including
what is the criteria to open up these
particular pieces of land and how will
the government prevent the same flawed
process from repeating itself today the
official opposition saying the only way
out of this for Premier Doug Ford is to
put the entire plan into reverse this
review is a sham right it's a colossal
waste of time and money we have two
independent investigations in
independent officers of the legislature
who've already dug into this they've
provided their conclusions there's no
coming back from this for this
government the people of Ontario are
angry they want the government to return
the land to the green belt they know it
was a dirty deal the premier needs to
immediately reverse course Colin no one
disputes Ontario needs more homes the
question is who benefits from this
particular land deal what is the bigger
picture here these continue to be
challenging times for Premier Doug Ford
this week he's lost a trusted and
well-regarded cabinet minister the
housing Minister Steve Clark the premier
of course forced to shuffle his cabinet
as a result and there are growing
questions about how much these homes are
actually going to cost in the green belt
will the average family be able to
afford them and what about those land
owners who stand to benefit because the
value of those lands have risen by eight
billion dollars according to the auditor
general and of course now the premier is
pivoting trying to shift some of the
attention away from his government and
onto the Bank of Canada the strategy now
blaming the Bank of Canada for the
interest rate hikes pleading with them
not to do any more of those interest
rate hikes it is a shift of blame that
critics say isn't going to take some of
the focus off of the Premier himself all
right Colin Demello in Toronto thanks
in Ottawa criminal trials are now
underway for two of the highest profile
leaders of last year's so-called Freedom
Convoy that shut down streets near
Parliament Hill for weeks Tamara Leach
and Chris Barber are charged with
Mischief obstructing police and
intimidation of parliament if convicted
they could be sentenced to time in jail
David Akin was in the courtroom today
David what does the prosecution have to
prove to make these charges stick well
you know Donna this is going to be a
closely watched trial for any number of
reasons not the least of which is we're
going to have two sides the crown and
the defense arguing about Free Speech
rights about the rights of protest now
in his opening statement the crown
prosecutor told the court that Charter
rights are not unqualified that they are
not absolute he promised to show how
Tamara Leach and Chris Barber were quote
key organizers of the protest that they
exercised influence over the placement
of trucks in downtown Ottawa they cause
roads to be obstructed and those two
pressured decision makers the prosecutor
told the court that quote this case is
not about their political views what's
at issue is the means Leach and barber
employed not the ends now the crown will
argue this was anything but a peaceful
process that these two crossed the lines
and they committed multiple crimes now
the defense lawyer for Barber had a very
brief reply in his in her opening
statement she said my client
participated in a lawful peaceful
protest and that the two of them
actually assisted police during the
protest Donna
David how is this trial going to play
out in terms of witnesses and testimony
well this is just day one of 16 days
that have been set aside for this
proceeding the crown expects to put out
120 exhibits including 50 videos we saw
one of those videos today a 12-minute
long compilation from the police of
video from those weeks in January and
February we're going to have 22
Witnesses police officers City officials
nine residents of downtown Ottawa and
here's something the defense will want
to exclude all those residents the
defense wants no residences residence on
the witness stand now both Tamara Leach
and Chris Barber were in court today
they were accompanied by their spouses
they didn't have much to say in the
court today and to be honest we're not
very sure if they're even going to
testify in this matter Donna all right
David Aiken in Ottawa thank you
jury selection has begun in another
high-profile trial in Ontario this one
involves a man facing terror-related
murder charges in the deaths of a Muslim
family leaders of the Muslim Community
call that attack a senseless act of
hatred
our community has been terrorized time
and time again and we will not stand for
it anymore we look forward to seeing how
our court system will send a message
that all Canadians should be protected
from terrorism no matter the ethnicity
or ideology of the attacker
Nathaniel veltman is accused of
deliberately hitting four members of the
afsal family with his truck while they
were out for an evening walk it happened
two years ago beltman has pleaded not
guilty a nine-year-old boy was also
seriously injured though he survived
manitobans are going to the polls next
month in a provincial election
happy to say that the Writ has
officially been dropped and that means
the 2023 Manitoba election campaign has
officially begun
if the progressive conservatives are
re-elected Heather Stephenson would be
the first woman in Manitoba history to
lead her party to Victory Bowl suggests
she's facing a strong Challenge from NDP
leader wab canoe who would become
Canada's first indigenous provincial
Premier if his party wins the most seats
the election is October 3rd the RCMP is
investigating a report that a former
former Canadian Royal Canadian Air Force
pilots are training pilots in China the
police say they began probing the case
when an allegation emerged last year it
involves accusations China may be paying
former members to train Air Force pilots
with the people's Liberation Army the
RCMP says it is aware of foreign actor
interference activity in Canada
prime minister Justin Trudeau is on a
tour of the indo-pacific region focusing
on strengthening economic ties and
reducing Canada's Reliance on China he
said today Canada is set to open an
export development office in Indonesia
Daria isri is traveling with the prime
minister
Indonesia is one of the world's fastest
growing economies and Canada doesn't
want to be left behind
prime minister Justin Trudeau landed in
Jakarta for the start of the asean
summit a meeting of Southeast Asian
Nations that make up Canada's second
largest export Market behind only the
U.S
Trudeau's first stop was the
presidential Palace Canada basketball
here he gifted the Indonesian leader
Joko Widodo a basketball jersey to thank
him for hosting the Canadian men's team
Ottawa is claiming its own symbolic
Victory by becoming a strategic member
of asean five decades after first
attending the Gathering it's really
important for Canadian companies and
exporters to grow in this region and
because when they do it means good jobs
back at home the deeper ties come after
years of criticism Canada has been an
inconsistent and unreliable partner we
haven't had a clear strategy until now
for the region and we haven't really had
a sustained presence Trudeau is in the
middle of trade negotiations with
Indonesia and also asean last year
Canada did 270 billion dollars in
business with the block that trade could
potentially be disrupted
by any number of threats threats like an
increasingly aggressive Beijing
ottawa's Outreach in Southeast Asia is a
central plank in its year old
indo-pacific strategy every country in
the indo-pacific their biggest trading
partner is is China so the more we're
doing in this region gives us a little
more
robust capacity
to deal with all of our bilateral
Partners another shared priority between
Canada and Indonesia fighting climate
change the consequences of a warming
Planet are disastrous here plans are
already underway to move the capital and
Donna Metro Jakarta has a population
roughly the size of Canada
wow turia Israeli and Jakarta thanks the
American first lady Jill Biden has
tested positive for covet 19. the White
House says she's experiencing only mild
symptoms and will remain at home in
Delaware this week President Biden who
spent part of the weekend with the first
lady tested negative for the virus
yesterday and today he is due to travel
to the G20 Summit in India on Thursday
the former leader of the far-right group
The Proud boys Enrique tario has been
sentenced to 22 years in prison for his
involvement in the attack on the U.S
Capitol on January 6 2021 he was
sentenced for the central role he played
in organizing a gang of his pro-trump
followers to attack the capital and stop
the peaceful transfer of Presidential
Power the 39 year old was not in
Washington at the time but prosecutors
showed he organized the far-right group
from afar in may he was convicted of
seditious conspiracy conspiring to
obstruct Congress and destroying
government property among other charges
his sentence of 22 years is the most
severe penalty so far in any of the
January 6th cases
the Labor Day weekend has come and gone
but summer is not over yet coming up how
a heat wave in central Canada could be a
sign of things to come
the start of September would usually
mean things start to cool down in Canada
but about a third of Canadians right now
are under an official heat warning it
stretches from near Manitoba's border
with Ontario right through to Quebec
City as Mike Armstrong explains a summer
that was cooler than average in Ontario
and Quebec might be going out like a
lion
reviews are in and the summer of 2023
won't be winning any awards after two
cooler and wetter than average months in
central Canada the heat has now shown up
oh really what everywhere I go I'm
sweating now it's not that there are
never any days over 30 degrees Celsius
in September but it is rare Montreal
hasn't been this hot at this time of the
year since 2019 in fact it's barely been
this hot all summer I mean the last day
in Montreal a temperature got above 30
was July the 6th and people had sort of
given up on summer it was over I mean
they had moved on
oh the weather doesn't seem to follow
the calendar as closely as it once did
and that means complications in Western
Quebec back to school is now on hold the
entire board closed its daycares
Elementary and high schools because the
classrooms don't have air conditioning
other boards with the same problem are
struggling through students know that if
they need a break they're allowed to sit
out we've got ice packs for students as
well remember now if you only focused on
the heat even with this heat wave 2023
doesn't really stand out
doesn't mean it hasn't been a rough ride
in April an ice storm knocked out power
for more than a million people that was
followed by severe spring flooding then
a storm that knocked out Bridges and
Roads
and the worst forest fires in history
there's the Red Sun again but the wild
weather has been wider than just Quebec
take Nova Scotia they had their worst
fire ever in terms of the amount of land
burned three weeks later on the same
land that had the worst flood ever come
on
climatologists say pointing at a heat
wave isn't proof of global warming even
if it is somewhat out of season it's
extreme events that highlight the
problem Calgary just hit a new all-time
high for Smoky days from forest fires
and it's still building on that record
climate change isn't just about
temperatures Rising Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal
still ahead what's happened to Spain's
soccer coach weeks after winning the
Women's World Cup
two weeks after that World Cup kissed
the Spanish soccer Federation has fired
the coach of its Women's World Cup
winning team Jorge vilda was hired in
2015. he's not the one who forcibly
kissed a player that was his boss soccer
Federation president Luis rubialis he's
been suspended for 90 days the
Federation has asked him to resign after
that now Infamous kiss on the lips of
Jenny Hermosa he claims it was
consensual she says it was not players
have said they will not take to the
field for the national team unless
changes are made on the managerial level
Spain's soccer Federation called the
firing of the coach one of the first
measures in restructuring by the
federation's interim president
[Music]
Hollywood stars won't let strikes steal
the spotlight at the Toronto
International Film Festival
[Music]
they're ready to roll out the red carpet
in Toronto Tiff officially kicks off
this Thursday the International Film
Festival is usually a place Canadian
fans can catch a glimpse of their
favorite stars but this year with two
ongoing strikes in Hollywood many
a-listers aren't coming as microwave
reports that's forced organizers to get
creative to keep some big names on the
Marquee YouTube
block streets
big crowds and selfies Galore
[Applause]
come to Define downtown Toronto every
September it's chaotic to say the least
but it's the price to pay for hosting
the Toronto International Film Festival
stopping back to the reality of 2023
Tiff is having to come to terms with a
festival that will likely have far less
traffic
why because the writers strike that
ground Hollywood to a halt is entering
its fourth month and the actors have
been on strike for nearly two months
faint hope of a deal getting done two
weeks ago quickly faded away leaving
Tiff's Brain Trust to plan for movie
premieres without the actors who star in
them you know and we roll with whatever
comes the festival just takes place in
the general world where stuff happens so
sometimes it's a pandemic sometimes it's
a doctor's strike we deal with whatever
comes and we are always able to put on a
great festival for our audience and as
it turns out all is not lost very few
films were ultimately pulled from Tiff's
lineup how much did we make today five
million dumb money for one will still be
featured without its cast attending but
Tiff found a loophole to get top stars
like Michael Keaton and Viggo Mortensen
to attend the festival you see they
won't be here as actors
they're allowed to yeah because they're
an actor they're directors they're
coming here as directors
so it appears the red carpet will be a
bit subdued but that's not entirely a
bad thing for up-and-coming Canadian
directors
no the glow guilty guilty guilty I think
this being one of the biggest film
festivals in the world
um I'm I feel like I can finally call
myself a film director Tiff he says is
still Tiff a film festival with the
cachet stars or not that can launch
careers microwave Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is from Chilliwack British
Columbia and it's a bit of a beast this
is a grisly barbecue it was made by
welding together 5 000 pieces of metal
it weighs more than 1800 kilograms or 4
000 pounds and it took eight months to
complete its creators or a group of
students competing in a National High
School welding competition
and their hard work paid off that
barbecue won the top prize of fifteen
thousand dollars nice smoke coming out
of the nose thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]